and a man remains in jail tonight after
crashing his off-road vehicle on
christmas eve this is what he and his
sister were riding in now the sister was
left with serious injuries madison
kimbrough spoke with a company that
deals with these vehicles on a regular
basis she's live tonight with a warning
for anyone who wants to ride in one
madison
yeah we see so many of these specialty
vehicles out on our roadways from utvs
to atvs and slingshots just like your
average car when riding these specialty
vehicles you have to stay safe
people think that because they're fast
you can just step on the gas and go but
these do tip and they roll over and
that's exactly what happened christmas
eve night when this man 26 year old
yasmani flamen was driving his utv and
crashed his 20 year old sister isabella
was left seriously injured and had to
have her right arm amputated las vegas
adrenaline junkies a company that rents
out these vehicles knows all too well
about the dangers involved people watch
them on social media and they see what
they are capable of they are vehicles
and people do die in them and they do
crash often people confuse atv's with
utv's a utv generally is bigger and
allows for more passengers they look at
them as toys and because they have roll
cages and they've seen them on social
media do really crazy fun things they
assume that anybody that gets behind the
wheel flemon faces a reckless driving
charge in a statement north las vegas
police say quote he was deliberately
doing doughnuts and as a result one of
the passengers in his vehicle was
seriously injured they're very powerful
and the way the suspension reacts it's
not going to handle the same way a car
does doing donuts on the street
that's very dangerous
and flammant is expected in court
tomorrow morning reporting live in north
las vegas madison kimbrough live local
now